[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir des enfants au soir ce que je
suis content pas trop chaud qu'au leur
nouveau jeu et quel est ton nouveau jeu
nounours je chat perché
c'est un jeu très amusant mais je suis
sûr que beaucoup d'enfants
le connaissent déjà aucune importance
patron nicolas et pimprenelle ne le
connaissent pas ce qu'on va s'amuser
mon échelle et givet propos qu'elle
vient où on trouve à ceux qui croient
avez vous déjà jouit à chat perché
qu'est ce que c'est ou pis je n'étais
sûr mais ne connaissent pas cet âge très
amusant et très simple il faut
s'attraper mais on ne peut attraper
quelqu'un que si la laitue bardin
défaut de se percher sur une chaise tu
rates vrai ou sur n'importe quoi crier à
perche et hugo nous attraper voilà les
garnements
ils se sont déjà perçus j'ai attrapé
paprota perché
je suis sur le tabourin yahoo tu m'as
patins prenait alors allons les enfants
ne vous des chutes et pas cher
alors c'est un peu nous attraper la
nonchalance autour du genou douloureux
ou lolo
[Musique]
vous ollu fois au au chat perché jamais
chute à bercy où je perdu
vous n'êtes plus fort que moi allons en
dormez-vous petit château chien la
prochaine fois méfiez vous c'est moi qui
cogne très haché câlin un jour encore et
nous jette après deux ans chez le beau
denis bananier nenê à ta mère t'aiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas trop patron schappert j'ai pas trop
et oui et alors on adore ce jeu super g
pas trop je vois mais quel âge as-tu je
les partage pas trop je suis immortel il
s'est vraiment gros nounours
allons
en route descend de son perchoir mon
immortel voilà voilà
on y va on le vend bonne nuit les petits
faites de beaux rêves octobre au
où
m
[Musique]